un artiste l'impôt deux pays la musique
n'a pas de frontières ça c'est évident
c'est un lieu commun
[Musique]
personne ne vous demande d'oublier vos
origines alors je m'intègre dans une
deuxième culture qui est la culture
française tout en gardant la première je
sais que parfois ces deux cultures earth
mais on fait avec on fait avec et ça se
passe
j'ai construit une maison dans la
musique et à froid du maroc de sites
d'ici ou là et ça me permet d'être enfin
complètement chez moi chez soi quand on
tient d'ailleurs c'est vrai que que ça a
joué un rôle dans mon inspiration est
dans mon écriture le fait que je sois
d'origine hongroise
le seul problème je crois le sait que
c'était dans ma réussite française
il est évident que mes origines
hongroises ont joué un rôle partie
l'egypte sans lien avec une valise
pleine de rêves mais sans argent élèves
d'être inconscient parce qu'elle ne le
pense pas
avec le recul de pouvoir le faire
le moment où je me suis senti qu'on qui
engloutit en quelque sorte par la france
est assez difficile à saisir
mais je crois que c'est le jour où pour
la première fois en regardant autour de
moi des paysages des monuments français
je ne me suis pas dit ils en ont de
belles choses chez eux mais nous en
avons de belles choses chez nous c'est
un métissage entre les deux cultures une
osmose et c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
depuis que vous arrivez en france jeudi
un peu la france aux maghrébins et jeudi
le maghreb aux français et je sais un
peu d'autres ce lien entre deux cultures
voilà j'ai eu la chance de faire le saut
de comparaison de vivre dans un immeuble
où chacun avait sa différence et on
vivait tous ensemble je crois que la
grandeur de ce pays la france justement
de vivre avec nos différences et
apporter nos qualités paul la grandeur
de ce pays un pays qu'il ne l'acceptent
pas le métissage est un pays qui
vieillit est un pays qui périclite
tous ces gens qui arrivent et pierre
pucheu vous avez vu comment ils sont
beaux ces gens là tous ces syriens ces
irakiens va y avoir plein de mariage
plein de couple qui pensent formés
et si rien de tel ça va raviver la
france je veux juste dire introduire les
conseils rachid arhab la prochaine fois
que vous présentez journal prime faire
un kif et le présenter comme ça j'espère
moi je suis debout je prends comme ça
bonjour vous êtes bien sûr le journal
télévisé français de france 2 c'est
rachid arhab et un problème
[Musique]